in a world where every Network spends
millions to get the attention of Emmy
voters the only way we knew how to build
high for our own Emmy nomination was to
make fun of the TV shows the voters work
off wait wait wait go back we got
nominated for an Emmy like an Emmy Emmy
that's awesome but wait then why are we
making fun of all their shows this is a
terrible idea you guys honest Emmys with
more than 400 scripted shows on
television no voter on earth has time to
watch them all so instead of just voting
for your friends this year here's an
honest refresher of the nominees for
Best Drama and Best Comedy Plus that ój
show cuz it was awesome get ready for an
action-packed thrill ride about two
Russian spies who take down America by
any wigs necessary in this winning
combination of great acting historical
drama and Felicity's but ruski business
he loved watching the rise and fall of
Walter White's meth Empire now strap in
for the prequel about the time his
lawyer brought a class-action lawsuit
against an assisted living facility some
of your clients have in fact been over
billed it's way better than it sounds
better not call him Saul because we're
two seasons in and his name is still
Jimmy the epic fantasy returns for a
season that I did even its own high
standards with massive casts epic set
pieces and some of the good guys
actually winning for once oh man next
season is gonna be brutal Downers and
Dragons prepare for another intense
season of political intrigue in this
smarter version of 24 where one woman
will do whatever it takes to upgrade
she's off her meds again look I love
Claire Danes and I know she can cry on
demand and all but it doesn't mean you
have to do it in every season let Mandy
Patinkin have a breakdown he would to
2-yard spice so-called life
the beautifully crafted Upstairs
Downstairs drama returns for even more
british people won't you stay and have
some tea big but just a for luncheon you
British invite him to dinner tomorrow
night I really don't know what happened
this season but kind of checked out
after cousin Matthew died fancy hats
Jack into the mind-bending cyber drama
that's the most realistic depiction of
hacking on television
although the bar for that has been set
pretty low you seem to know your way
around the computer I'm trying it's
moving too fast we're going to to the
blinky boxes left to go back by club
netflix changed the game and they're
still going strong
with a prestige drama that mixes the
West Wing with Deadpool
oh hello did you think I'd forgotten you
in this twisted nightmare version of
American politics that keeps getting
one-upped by reality actually I was only
kidding you can get the baby out of the
wolf of DC get ready for the reigning
champion of political satire in the
prestige comedy that mixes the West Wing
with the office in this twisted
nightmare version of American politics
that also keeps getting one up by
reality I don't know what I said ah I
don't remember I'm not with her
streaming live on Amazon once you figure
out how to actually log in and find it
comes the messy family drama D that
proves you can be gay trans or straight
and still be a dick okay so there we go
it's settled done no I'm not you cannot
do anything hey now I'm a woman now Mike
judge brings us a teracle genius to the
world of internet startups where the
egotistical antisocial billionaires get
taken down a peg
I just got humiliated by a teenager and
you give me this tampon ad by a team of
egotistical antisocial wannabe
billionaires and if you don't fund us
you're a [ __ ] dot-com tirage she was
kidnapped by a sexually abusive cult
leader she was trapped in a bunker for
years now she's out and she's looking
for a job in the boyfriend wacky room
curl up with America's favorite comfort
show that after seven seasons still
hasn't told us who's filming them so I
took a vegan cooking class and my new
Fang is vacant seriously who are they
talking to not as modern as transparents
family enjoy the latest and greatest New
York City show about nothing in the
rom-com everyone loves about the
problems that only Aziz Ansari has this
is supposed to be the best taco what I'm
supposed to do now point the second best
taco like some kind of Oh
everybody loves Aziz from the creator of
America's Next Top Model comes the
hilarious sitcom in the tradition of The
Cosby Show good times and fresh prints
it gives a fresh funny new take on the
same old racist bush hit The Jeffersons
had to deal with rioting broke out in
some 40 US cities last night and it
looks like we're getting word now a
protest across the country becoming
violent
come on society black family matters
you already lived through the endless
news coverage the unlikable cast of
characters and the shocking twist ending
now oh J is back on television and it's
amazing Wow
I did not see that coming the People vs
OJ Simpson vs. Fargo seriously that's a
really tough category and those are your
nominees so when you're filling out your
ballot don't forget to vote for the
short-form variety series that's honest
enough to pander directly to you well
hopefully not pissing you off too much I
mean we're cool right well this is gonna
be awkward
thanks for the consideration Emmy voters
and be sure to check out our most recent
movie fights with Seth Rogen who gave us
advice for the big show I just remember
you to pay for drinks in the seats are
uncomfortable so bring a pillow in your
wallet you'll have to speak up I'm
wearing a towel fireball the demagogue
in we are bad guys it's what we do
how screen junkies will stand behind
House Stark as we did for six seasons
marmalade in my trousers on a Thursday
afternoon